Bentornati a capire le informazioni e il calcolo quantistico. Mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il direttore tecnico per l'educazione a IBM
Quantum. Questa è la sedicesima e ultima lezione della serie e il tema della lezione è il calcolo quantistico tollerante ai guasti.
Nel corso delle tre lezioni precedenti abbiamo visto diversi esempi di codici di correzione degli errori quantistici che possono rilevare e consentirci di
correggere errori quantistici purché non se ne verifichino troppi. Se vogliamo usare la correzione degli errori per il Quantum Computing, tuttavia, ci sono ancora molti
problemi con cui fare i conti, inclusa la realtà che i nostri gate quantistici, le misurazioni e le preparazioni di stato
saranno probabilmente essi stessi imperfetti. Quindi, per esempio, se dobbiamo eseguire la correzione degli errori su uno
o più qubit che sono stati codificati usando un codice di correzione degli errori quantistici, dovremmo farlo con gate e misurazioni che essi stessi
hanno una probabilità di non funzionare correttamente. E ciò significa non solo non riuscire a rilevare o correggere gli errori, ma possibilmente
introdurne di nuovi. Inoltre, dobbiamo anche eseguire i calcoli effettivi a cui siamo interessati di nuovo con gate che non sono
perfetti. E certamente non possiamo rischiare di decodificare le informazioni quantistiche per eseguire i calcoli e poi
ri-codificarle una volta fatto perché gli errori potrebbero colpire quando la protezione di un codice di correzione degli errori quantistici è assente.
Ciò significa che dobbiamo capire come eseguire gate quantistici direttamente su qubit logici che non restino mai senza la
protezione di un codice di correzione degli errori quantistici. Questo è un compito arduo, ma è noto che purché il livello di rumore
scenda al di sotto di un certo valore soglia, è in effetti possibile eseguire calcoli quantistici arbitrariamente grandi in modo affidabile usando hardware rumoroso, almeno
in teoria. E discuteremo questo fatto di fondamentale importanza più avanti nella lezione. Ecco una breve panoramica della
lezione. Inizieremo con un modello di base per il Quantum Computing tollerante ai guasti inclusa una breve discussione
dei modelli di rumore insieme a una metodologia generale per implementare un circuit quantistico in modo tollerante ai
guasti. Passeremo poi al problema della propagazione degli errori nei circuit quantistici tolleranti ai guasti e come
controllarla. In particolare, discuterò le implementazioni di gate transversali che offrono un modo molto semplice per controllare la propagazione degli errori.
Sebbene ci sia una limitazione fondamentale che ci impedisce di usare questo metodo
esclusivamente. Parlerò anche di una diversa metodologia che coinvolge i cosiddetti magic state che offre un percorso diverso per controllare la propagazione degli errori
nei circuit quantistici tolleranti ai guasti. Sebbene non sia l'unico metodo noto e infine la lezione
si conclude con una discussione piuttosto ad alto livello del teorema della soglia a cui ho accennato poco fa.
Questo teorema afferma che circuit quantistici arbitrariamente grandi possono essere implementati in modo affidabile purché il tasso di errore di tutti i componenti
coinvolti scenda al di sotto di un certo valore soglia finito. In generale, questo valore soglia
dipende dal codice di correzione degli errori che usiamo nonché dalle scelte specifiche che facciamo per le implementazioni tolleranti ai guasti di
gate e misurazioni quantistici ma non dalla dimensione del circuit da implementare. E questo ci dà un buon motivo per credere che i calcoli quantistici su larga scala
diventino un giorno realtà. Inizieremo discutendo un modello di base per il Quantum Computing tollerante ai guasti
che è naturalmente basato su circuit quantistici e codici di correzione degli errori quantistici. Ai fini di questa discussione,
immaginiamo di avere un circuit quantistico che speriamo di implementare come quello mostrato qui. Si dà il caso che questo sia
un circuit di teleportazione inclusa la preparazione dell'EBIT. Ma i dettagli non hanno molta importanza per questa discussione. E potresti immaginare che
questo sia qualsiasi altro circuit quantistico, possibilmente un circuit molto più grande che include preparazioni di stato, operazioni
unitarie e misurazioni. Questo circuit, naturalmente, rappresenta un ideale, e un'implementazione effettiva
di esso non sarà perfetta. La domanda naturale da porsi è cosa potrebbe andare
storto? Beh, ci sono molte cose che potrebbero andare storte. Per esempio, le inizializzazioni di stato in genere non saranno
perfette. Ovviamente i gate unitari non saranno perfetti e nemmeno le
misurazioni. E inoltre i qubit stessi saranno suscettibili al rumore, inclusa la decoerenza, in ogni momento
del calcolo, anche quando a questi qubit non sta succedendo nulla e stanno semplicemente memorizzando informazioni quantistiche. In altre parole, praticamente
tutto potrebbe andare storto. C'è però un'eccezione o almeno questa è un'ipotesi tipica e
cioè che qualsiasi calcolo classico coinvolto probabilmente non sarà difettoso perché a tutti gli effetti i
calcoli classici sono essenzialmente perfetti. Quindi per esempio, se eseguiamo un algoritmo di matching classico per
calcolare le correzioni per gli errori del surface code, non dobbiamo davvero preoccuparci che questo calcolo classico possa essere difettoso. Ma qualsiasi cosa che riguardi direttamente
le informazioni quantistiche potrebbe esserlo. Naturalmente, abbiamo bisogno di un modello preciso attraverso cui associare
probabilità a vari eventi che potrebbero andare storto. E se volessimo, potremmo elaborare un modello complesso quanto ci piace per sperare di riflettere qualunque cosa
accada effettivamente nella realtà. Se il modello è troppo complicato, tuttavia, potrebbe risultare difficile o impossibile da usare o da dire
qualcosa di interessante. Un esempio molto semplice di modello di rumore che le persone considerano spesso
è il modello di rumore stocastico indipendente dove gli errori o i guasti che colpiscono diversi componenti in
momenti diversi o in altre parole, posizioni diverse nel circuit sono indipendenti.
Per esempio, potremmo dire che ogni gate fallisce con una certa probabilità, che le inversioni del bit e le phase flip avvengono ai qubit memorizzati con una diversa
probabilità per unità di tempo e così via. Ma l'assunzione è che non c'è correlazione tra i diversi
errori. Ora, potresti obiettare a quel modello perché probabilmente ci saranno alcune correlazioni tra
gli errori. Per esempio, c'è probabilmente una piccola probabilità di un errore catastrofico che elimina tutti i qubit in una volta.
O forse più probabilmente, ci potrebbero essere errori localizzati che tuttavia colpiscono più componenti.
E nessuno dice il contrario. Ma tuttavia, questo modello rappresenta una semplice linea di base che in
sostanza rappresenta l'idea che la natura è imprevedibile, ma non è malintenzionata e non sta cercando di rovinare intenzionalmente
i calcoli quantistici. Ci sono altri modelli di rumore probabilmente più realistici che sono spesso considerati. E indipendentemente dal
modello che scegliamo, se si scopre che il nostro modello ci porta fuori strada e impariamo qualcosa di nuovo sugli errori in
qualunque sistema con cui stiamo lavorando, possiamo naturalmente formulare e considerare diversi modelli di errore. Quindi,
daremo un'occhiata a una strategia di base per implementare i circuit quantistici in modo tollerante ai guasti. Quindi consideriamo un dato
circuit quantistico logico, ovvero un circuit quantistico ideale che siamo interessati a eseguire. Per esempio, potremmo considerare lo stesso circuit di
prima, che ora è leggermente allargato perché avremo bisogno di un po' più di spazio per l'implementazione tollerante ai guasti. Prima
di tutto, le preparazioni di stato, i gate unitari e le misurazioni non saranno eseguiti direttamente come gate singoli o come
misurazioni o preparazioni di stato su un singolo qubit, ma piuttosto saranno eseguiti da cosiddetti gadget, che
potrebbero ciascuno coinvolgere più qubit e più operazioni. Qui in questo diagramma, ho
illustrato questo disegnando riquadri viola attorno a queste cose. E puoi pensare a questi riquadri viola come a piccoli circuit o operazioni che sono
semplicemente etichettate in base a qualunque preparazione di stato o gate intendiamo implementare. In secondo luogo, dobbiamo proteggere
i qubit usando un codice di correzione degli errori. Quindi non saranno i qubit logici stessi a connettere questi diversi gadget, ma piuttosto i gadget agiscono sui
qubit fisici che codificano questi qubit logici. E vale la pena sottolineare qui che i qubit logici di cui ci interessa
non sono mai esposti, il che significa che questi qubit logici trascorreranno tutta la loro vita protetti da qualunque
codice di correzione degli errori quantistici stiamo usando. E infine, eseguiamo la correzione degli errori sui nostri qubit codificati
ripetutamente nel corso del calcolo, fondamentalmente ogni volta che ne abbiamo l'opportunità. Ed è di fondamentale importanza che lo facciamo.
In modo intuitivo, man mano che si verificano gli errori, la casualità o l'incertezza inizia ad accumularsi nello stato dei nostri
qubit e dobbiamo lavorare costantemente per rimuovere questa casualità o entropia. E questo avviene attraverso la correzione degli errori.
Quindi puoi pensare a questi passaggi di correzione degli errori come a piccoli frigoriferi logici o pompe di calore che
consentono ai qubit logici di rimanere freddi in modo che il calcolo possa funzionare correttamente.
Una volta fatte tutte queste scelte, ovvero la selezione di tutti i gadget nonché il codice e assumendo un particolare modello di rumore, c'è una
domanda fondamentale che possiamo farci e cioè, questo sta effettivamente aiutando? Stiamo migliorando le cose o
le stiamo peggiorando? Se c'è troppo rumore, potremmo molto probabilmente stare peggiorando le cose,
proprio come il codice Shore a 9 qubit peggiora le cose se la probabilità di un errore è troppo alta.
Ma se il rumore è al di sotto di una certa soglia, allora tutto questo lavoro extra ci porterà da qualche parte. E come discuteremo verso la fine della lezione,
si aprono percorsi per un'ulteriore riduzione dell'errore. In questa parte della lezione, discuteremo la propagazione degli errori nei circuit
quantistici tolleranti ai guasti aventi la struttura di base che ho appena descritto. Questo si rivela essere una
preoccupazione principale perché se non riusciamo a controllare la propagazione degli errori, gli errori sopraffaranno rapidamente i nostri sforzi di correzione degli errori.
Ma se siamo in grado di controllare la propagazione degli errori, allora il nostro codice avrà molte più possibilità
di stare al passo in modo che gli errori possano essere corretti a un tasso abbastanza elevato da consentire ai nostri calcoli di
funzionare. Il punto di partenza per questa discussione è la realizzazione che i gate a due qubit o i gate a qubit multipli più
in generale possono propagare gli errori anche quando funzionano correttamente.
Per esempio, considera un gate CNOT. E supponiamo che si verifichi un errore X sul qubit di controllo prima del gate CNOT
da eseguire. Beh, un errore X funziona proprio come un gate X. E troviamo che
il circuit a sinistra è equivalente a quello a destra dove gli errori X si verificano su entrambi i qubit dopo il gate CNOT.
Questa è una propagazione di errori perché la sfortunata posizione dell'errore X a sinistra lo trasforma effettivamente in
due errori X a destra. E non riusciremo mai ad aggirare questo. Finché usiamo gate CNOT, c'è sempre
una possibilità che si verifichi un errore X sul qubit di controllo appena prima, che poi si propaga a due errori X
dopo. Ma come vedremo, purché adottiamo misure per limitare il danno che questo causa, staremo bene. E tra l'altro,
lo stesso fenomeno si verifica quando abbiamo un errore Z sul qubit target appena prima di un CNOT. E ne abbiamo discusso
prima e puoi verificare queste uguaglianze semplicemente eseguendo le moltiplicazioni oppure puoi verificarle usando
Qiskit. Il succo è che in entrambi i casi ciò causerà errori correlati su più qubit. E ovviamente non
dovremmo dimenticare che i gate CNOT stessi potrebbero anche essere difettosi il che può causare errori correlati
aggiuntivi. Per aggiungere alla nostra preoccupazione, gate a due qubit successivi potrebbero propagare questi errori ancora di più.
Per esempio, se abbiamo tre gate CNOT come questo, proprio come troviamo quando misuriamo i generatori di stabilizzatore X per esempio, allora un singolo errore può
propagarsi rapidamente a più qubit. E se questo accade all'interno di un singolo blocco di codice, per esempio, ovvero un insieme di
qubit che insieme codificano un qubit logico, qualunque codice di correzione degli errori abbiamo scelto non avrà
alcuna possibilità perché i codici sono progettati per correggere errori a basso peso, non errori ad alto peso come questo.
E quindi questo è qualcosa che dobbiamo tenere in primo piano mentre pensiamo ai gadget e agli
step di correzione degli errori nei circuit quantistici tolleranti ai guasti. Il modo più semplice noto per mitigare la propagazione degli errori nei circuit
quantistici tolleranti ai guasti è implementare i gate in modo transversale e spiegherò cosa significa
tra poco. Quindi teniamo la figura della nostra implementazione tollerante ai guasti sullo schermo solo come aiuto visivo.
L'idea qui è che per alcuni codici di correzione degli errori quantistici, certi gate possono essere implementati in modo transversale, il che
significa implementarli usando gadget che sono prodotti tensoriali di operazioni dove ogni operazione agisce solo su una
singola posizione di qubit all'interno di ogni blocco di codice. È più facile spiegarlo attraverso alcuni esempi. Il primo e
probabilmente più semplice esempio è l'implementazione transversale dei gate di Pauli.
L'idea è che vorremmo costruire gadget per ciascuno dei gate nel nostro circuit. E in tutti i casi, quei gadget
operano su blocchi di codice come vediamo per i gate X e Z alla fine del nostro circuit di teleportazione. Ovviamente, non
possiamo decodificare, applicare un gate di Pauli e poi ri-codificare perché questo lascerebbe un qubit logico non protetto e gli errori
potrebbero propagarsi all'interno del blocco di codice come risultato della ri-codifica.
Fortunatamente, non abbiamo bisogno di farlo purché usiamo un codice stabilizzatore perché ogni codice stabilizzatore consente di
applicare operazioni di Pauli direttamente ai nostri qubit logici. E in effetti, possiamo farlo con un prodotto tensoriale di gate di Pauli
sui qubit fisici usati per la codifica.
Per esempio, se consideriamo il surface code 3x3 che è emerso alla fine della lezione precedente, allora possiamo implementare gate X e Z sul qubit logico
codificato da questo codice mettendo insieme gate X e Z insieme a gate identità nei pattern che sono
suggeriti qui. Questa è un'implementazione transversale di questi gate perché ognuna di queste singole operazioni di gate
agisce solo su una singola posizione di qubit all'interno di ogni blocco di codice.
Stiamo usando solo gate su un singolo qubit qui, quindi è in un certo senso banale, ma in ogni caso, gadget come questo non causeranno la propagazione degli errori.
Ora, uno qualsiasi dei gate singoli in un gadget come questo potrebbe fallire, e ciò introdurrà
errori, ma eseguiremo sempre la correzione degli errori immediatamente dopo ogni gadget. E finché il tasso di errore è
sufficientemente basso, il codice di correzione degli errori correggerà quegli errori.
E come ho detto, questo è sempre possibile per i gate di Pauli per ogni codice stabilizzatore.
Sebbene tu debba identificare il pattern giusto di gate di Pauli nei gadget per implementare correttamente qualunque operazione di Pauli logica stai
cercando. Per un altro esempio che coinvolge gate a due qubit, questa volta possiamo considerare implementazioni transversali
di gate CNOT. In particolare, per ogni codice CSS, possiamo sempre implementare un gate CNOT
tra due qubit logici semplicemente eseguendo gate CNOT su coppie corrispondenti di qubit fisici.
E questo soddisfa la condizione di essere transversale perché ognuno di questi gate CNOT singoli agisce solo
su una singola posizione di qubit all'interno di ogni blocco di codice. Per esempio, il primo gate CNOT agisce solo sul qubit più in alto
all'interno di ogni blocco di codice. il secondo gate CNOT agisce solo sul secondo qubit dall'alto e così
via. In questo caso, potremmo avere una propagazione di errori perché i gate CNOT propagano gli errori e non c'è
modo di evitarlo. Ma la chiave è che la propagazione degli errori non avviene mai all'interno di un singolo blocco di codice. Per esempio,
un errore X potrebbe verificarsi sul qubit più in alto del blocco di codice superiore appena prima che il gadget venga eseguito e il primo gate CNOT
all'interno del gadget propagherà quell'errore al qubit più in alto nel blocco inferiore. Ma i due errori risultanti sono
ora in blocchi di codice separati. Quindi i passaggi di correzione degli errori che avvengono dopo il gadget saranno in grado di correggere quei singoli errori perché quelli
errori colpiscono solo un singolo qubit all'interno di ogni blocco di codice.
Al contrario, se la propagazione degli errori fosse avvenuta all'interno dello stesso blocco di codice, allora potremmo essere in difficoltà perché la
propagazione degli errori starebbe trasformando un errore a basso peso in un errore a peso più alto che il nostro codice potrebbe non essere in grado di gestire.
Questa implementazione non funziona per i codici non CSS, ma purché usiamo un codice CSS, possiamo sempre implementare i gate CNOT
in modo transversale in questo modo. E per un altro esempio, ogni
gate di Clifford può essere implementato in modo transversale per il codice Steane. E in effetti per qualsiasi color code che è una delle cose davvero belle dei color code
in particolare un gate Hadamard su un qubit logico può essere implementato eseguendo gate Hadamard individualmente su
ciascuno dei qubit fisici e un gate S logico può essere implementato non con un gate S su ogni qubit ma piuttosto con un
gate S dagger su ogni qubit fisico. Quindi il succo è che le implementazioni di gate transversali sono intrinsecamente
tolleranti ai guasti perché non propagano mai gli errori all'interno di un singolo blocco di codice il che dà ai passaggi di correzione degli errori una possibilità di correggere
qualunque errore venga introdotto o propagato dai gate usati per questi gadget. Quindi è ottimo ed è un
modo davvero semplice per costruire gadget tolleranti ai guasti e ci sono codici diversi che consentono implementazioni transversali di gate diversi come
i gate T ma purtroppo è impossibile per qualsiasi codice non banale implementare un
set universale di gate in modo transversale il che è un fatto noto come teorema di Eastin-Knill in termini più tecnici ciò che
dice è che finché il nostro codice ha distanza almeno due il set di gate che può essere implementato in modo transversale genererà necessariamente un
insieme discreto di operazioni a meno di una fase globale e quindi questo set non è universale perché i set di gate universali
generano necessariamente infinitamente molte operazioni. Non spiegherò la dimostrazione di questo teorema che fa uso di alcuni
fatti di base sui gruppi di Lie e le algebre di Lie che non sono prerequisiti per questa serie. Ma l'idea di base è
che le famiglie infinite di operazioni transversali non possono mantenerci nello spazio del codice perché minuscole
differenze nelle operazioni transversali sono ben approssimate da operazioni di Pauli a basso peso che il codice rileva come
errori. Quindi siamo molto felici quando possiamo implementare i gate in modo transversale. Ma per qualunque codice scegliamo, sappiamo che avremo sempre alcuni gate che non possiamo implementare in questo modo. E quindi dobbiamo cercare gadget alternativi. Dal
teorema di Eastin-Knill, sappiamo che non è possibile implementare un set universale di gate quantistici in modo transversale anche
per un misero codice di correzione degli errori quantistici di distanza 2. Quindi dobbiamo trovare altri modi per implementare i gate in modo tollerante ai
guasti almeno per alcuni gate. Un modo ben noto per farlo è attraverso l'uso dei cosiddetti magic
state. Ai fini di questa discussione, ricordiamo i gate S e T che sono
gate su un singolo qubit definiti come mostrato qui sullo schermo. Osserviamo anche che prima S è un'operazione di Clifford
il che deriva dalla nostra definizione di operazioni di Clifford. Ma puoi anche verificare che coniugare una matrice di Pauli con S restituisce sempre più o meno un'altra
matrice di Pauli. E secondo, T non è un'operazione di Clifford. E in effetti, se combiniamo T con Hadamard e CNOT, entrambi
operazioni di Clifford, otteniamo un set universale di gate quantistici. Quindi non possiamo implementare un gate T
usando solo operazioni di Clifford e misurazioni della base standard da soli. Ma possiamo in effetti implementare un gate T usando
operazioni di Clifford e misurazioni della base standard se in aggiunta abbiamo una copia dello stato mostrato qui
sullo schermo, che è il gate T applicato a uno stato più.
Questo stato si chiama magic state, sebbene non sia unico in questo senso.
Il termine magic state è usato anche per riferirsi a stati diversi che svolgono un ruolo simile a questo in variazioni di questo intero
schema. Per esempio, questo circuit mostrato qui fa il lavoro. E non è troppo difficile verificarlo.
Ecco lo stato iniziale con il sistema superiore a destra. E se applichiamo il gate CNOT e semplifichiamo, otteniamo lo
stato mostrato qui.
Quindi se misuriamo il qubit inferiore e otteniamo zero che accade con probabilità 1/2, non eseguiamo il gate S e l'output è T applicato a s.
E se misuriamo uno che accade anche con probabilità 1/2, ovviamente applichiamo il gate S e il risultato netto è
che l'output è di nuovo T applicato a s.
Questo non è l'unico modo per farlo tra l'altro. Ci sono altri circuit simili che svolgono lo stesso compito ma questo è un modo per farlo.
E se misuriamo uno che accade anche con probabilità 1/2 ovviamente applichiamo il gate S e il risultato netto è
che l'output è di nuovo T applicato a s. Questo non è l'unico modo per farlo tra l'altro. Ci sono altri circuit simili
che svolgono lo stesso compito ma è un modo per farlo. Questo è un esempio in qualche modo semplificato di quello che è noto come quantum gate teleportation, a cui ho accennato nella lezione 4, dove la teleportazione è usata
non per inviare qubit, ma per applicare gate. Il collegamento con la teleportazione potrebbe non essere del tutto chiaro qui perché, come ho
detto, questa è una versione semplificata, con cui possiamo cavarcela perché T è diagonale. Ma se sei interessato a
saperne di più, le parole chiave sono quantum gate teleportation.
E potremmo fare qualcosa di simile per implementare un gate S dove questa volta gli unici gate di cui abbiamo bisogno sono un gate CNOT e un gate Z insieme alla misurazione
il che è utile se non abbiamo un'implementazione transversale di un gate S. Quindi è interessante ma non è
del tutto chiaro che questo aiuti davvero. Nel caso dell'implementazione del gate T, per esempio, stiamo
riuscendo ad applicare un gate T a uno stato di input. Ma per farlo, sembra che stiamo applicando un gate T a uno stato più per ottenere un
magic state. E la situazione è simile per l'implementazione del gate S. Il punto è che non
è necessario prima creare uno stato più e poi applicare un gate T per ottenere un magic state. Ci sono altri possibili modi per ottenere questo stato. E in
particolare, possiamo farlo senza doverci preoccupare di propagare errori in qualunque calcolo su cui stiamo lavorando perché i magic state possono essere creati
separatamente. Questo consente un'implementazione tollerante ai guasti di un gate T come descriverò brevemente ora.
Prima, non eseguiremo effettivamente il semplice circuit a due qubit mostrato qui, ma invece eseguiremo questo circuit usando
qubit codificati in qualunque codice di correzione degli errori stiamo usando per la nostra implementazione tollerante ai guasti. Il che significa che i
gate unitari e le misurazioni sono eseguiti da gadget tolleranti ai guasti. E ciò significa che abbiamo bisogno anche dei nostri
magic state codificati. Quindi tutto sarà tollerante ai guasti purché riusciamo ad avere in mano
magic state codificati. Stiamo assumendo qui tra l'altro che abbiamo già un gadget tollerante ai guasti per un gate S. Se
stessimo usando il codice Steane per esempio, potremmo semplicemente implementare il gate S in modo transversale. E per i codici per cui ciò non funziona, un'opzione è
usare prima questo intero schema per implementare un gate S in modo tollerante ai guasti e poi usare quella implementazione qui.
Sebbene non sia l'unica opzione. Ma comunque, tornando all'implementazione, la domanda importante che rimane è come mettiamo le mani
su un magic state codificato dato che non abbiamo ancora un'implementazione tollerante ai guasti di un gate T per rendere ciò
semplice? E l'idea chiave è che possiamo usare un processo probabilistico per creare magic state codificati. E se non
funziona, va bene. Possiamo semplicemente buttare via i tentativi falliti e riprovare.
E ciò non disturba il calcolo che stiamo effettivamente cercando di eseguire perché la creazione di magic state viene fatta
separatamente. Un modo tipico in cui ciò viene fatto è attraverso un processo noto come magic state distillation. E funziona così.
Abbiamo un certo circuit noto come distillatore. Inseriamo in questo distillatore una raccolta di magic state rumorosi
e poi misuriamo tutti gli output tranne uno. E se condizioniamo sul fatto che tutti i risultati delle misurazioni siano zero,
allora ciò che accade è che ciò che esce è un magic state meno rumoroso, che può poi essere uno dei qubit inseriti in
un altro distillatore. E il processo continua finché non falliamo perché uno dei risultati delle misurazioni è diverso da zero e riproviamo o abbiamo un magic
state di qualità sufficientemente alta da poterlo usare in modo sicuro per implementare un gate T nel calcolo che ci interessa.
Ci sono diversi modi noti per costruire un distillatore come questo, ma funzionano tutti in modo sostanzialmente uguale, ovvero sono decoder per codici stabilizzatori,
il che significa che sono inverse dei circuit di codifica, il che è piacevole perché significa che il distillatore può essere un'operazione di
Clifford. E infine, questo processo di distillazione è in realtà qualcosa che avviene al livello del qubit logico. Quindi in realtà è tutto
fatto usando gadget per il distillatore e le misurazioni. Questo processo deve
iniziare da qualche parte. Ma finché il tasso di rumore non è troppo alto, è possibile creare magic state rumorosi ma abbastanza buoni
da avviarlo. Per esempio, applicando un effettivo gate T rumoroso a un qubit in uno stato più e poi
codificando quel qubit. Quindi questa è stata una descrizione molto ad alto livello, ma spero di averti dato un'idea approssimativa di come funziona.
È piuttosto più complicato che implementare gate in modo transversale, ma tuttavia offre un modo per implementare un set universale di gate quantistici
in modo tollerante ai guasti, mentre le implementazioni di gate transversali da sole non possono farlo. A volte si afferma
che l'overhead per usare i magic state per implementare gate in modo tollerante ai guasti lungo queste linee sarebbe molto alto
dove la stragrande maggioranza del lavoro va nella distillazione dei magic state e l'esecuzione del calcolo effettivo è più un
dettaglio di secondo piano. Ma questo in realtà non è così chiaro e ci sono state analisi dettagliate che rivelano che questo metodo
potrebbe essere in effetti pratico. Ci sono diversi altri schemi noti per implementare gate in modo tollerante ai guasti. La deformazione del codice e la commutazione del codice sono nomi
associati ad alcuni di questi schemi e nuovi modi continuano a essere sviluppati e raffinati ma non descriverò quei
metodi in questa lezione. C'è un altro problema importante riguardante le implementazioni tolleranti ai guasti dei circuit quantistici e
riguarda i passaggi di correzione degli errori stessi. Quindi non si tratta di implementare gate. Si tratta di fare la
correzione degli errori effettiva. Il problema è che se pensiamo ai semplici circuit che
abbiamo visto per la prima volta nella lezione 14 per misurare i generatori stabilizzatori basati sulla stima di fase, troviamo che non sono
essi stessi tolleranti ai guasti perché potrebbero potenzialmente causare la propagazione degli errori all'interno di un singolo blocco di codice.
Questo riporta all'idea che qualsiasi cosa che coinvolga informazioni quantistiche è suscettibile agli errori e ciò include i circuit che sono essi stessi destinati
a correggere gli errori. Questo sembra piuttosto problematico, ma ci sono in effetti più soluzioni note a questo problema. Menzioneò solo alcune di
esse, sebbene non ne spiegherò nessuna in dettaglio. E tra l'altro, se ti stai facendo l'idea che il Quantum Computing tollerante ai guasti sia
complicato e ci siano molti dettagli di cui preoccuparsi, allora è certamente comprensibile perché è vero. Ci sono molte parti in movimento
qui e la mia intenzione con questa lezione non è spiegare tutti i dettagli ma piuttosto darti solo una introduzione di base a come funziona tutto
quanto. Un metodo per la correzione degli errori quantistici tollerante ai guasti è noto come correzione degli errori di Shor dal nome di Peter
Shor che per primo ha proposto questo metodo. L'idea è di eseguire ogni misurazione della sindrome usando un cosiddetto cat state,
che è la stessa cosa di uno stato GHZ quando abbiamo tre qubit, ma può essere generalizzato a qualsiasi numero di qubit che corrisponde al peso del generatore stabilizzatore
che intendiamo misurare. In particolare, il circuit mostrato qui funziona per misurare un generatore stabilizzatore. E può essere
dimostrato che questo metodo non causa la propagazione degli errori all'interno di un blocco di codice.
Rende necessario creare il cat state stesso. E per farlo funzionare in modo affidabile in presenza di errori e gate potenzialmente difettosi, il metodo in realtà
richiede che eseguiamo ripetutamente circuit come questo e facciamo inferenze su dove potrebbero essersi verificati diversi errori durante il
processo. Un metodo alternativo è noto come correzione degli errori di Steane che è stato proposto per la prima volta da Andrew Steane e questo
metodo funziona diversamente e funziona solo per i codici CSS. In questo metodo, non eseguiamo effettivamente le misurazioni della sindrome sugli stati quantistici codificati
nel circuit che stiamo cercando di eseguire, ma invece propaghiamo intenzionalmente gli errori su un sistema workspace
e poi misuriamo quel sistema e rileviamo classicamente gli errori. Questa figura mostrata qui mostra come farlo per gli errori X nel qual caso i qubit workspace
sono inizialmente impostati su una codifica di uno stato più. Quindi questo è fondamentalmente una
implementazione transversale di un gate CNOT che non dovrebbe fare nulla perché il target è in uno stato più. Ma se ci
fossero errori X nei qubit superiori, si propagheranno verso il sistema inferiore e saranno rilevati. C'è anche un metodo simile per rilevare gli errori Z
che non è mostrato qui. C'è anche un metodo correlato noto come correzione degli errori di Knill proposto per la prima volta da Manny Knill
ed è basato sulla teleportazione piuttosto che su un CNOT transversale e ciò gli consente di funzionare per codici stabilizzatori arbitrari
e non solo per i codici CSS.
L'ultima cosa di cui discuterò in questa lezione è un teorema molto importante noto come teorema della soglia. Ecco un
enunciato un po' informale del teorema. Dice che se abbiamo un qualsiasi circuit quantistico con n gate dove n può essere grande quanto vogliamo, allora è
possibile implementare quel circuit con alta accuratezza usando un circuit quantistico rumoroso a condizione che il livello di rumore
sia al di sotto di un certo valore soglia che è indipendente da n. E inoltre, non è troppo costoso farlo nel
senso che la dimensione del circuit rumoroso richiesto è dell'ordine di n per un certo potere costante del logaritmo di
n. Per enunciare il teorema in modo più formale è necessario essere specifici riguardo al modello di rumore, cosa che non farò in questa lezione.
Può per esempio essere dimostrato per il modello di rumore stocastico indipendente che ho menzionato prima dove gli errori si verificano
indipendentemente in ogni posizione possibile nel circuit con una probabilità strettamente inferiore a questo valore soglia. Ma può anche essere
dimostrato per modelli di rumore più generali dove possono esserci correlazioni tra gli errori. Ora, questo è un risultato
teorico e il modo tipico in cui viene dimostrato non si traduce necessariamente in qualcosa che faremmo effettivamente nella pratica, ma è tuttavia un
teorema molto importante in termini pratici. E il motivo è che dice fondamentalmente che non c'è nessuna barriera fondamentale per eseguire
calcoli quantistici usando componenti rumorosi.
Purché il tasso di errore per questi componenti sia al di sotto di questo valore soglia, possono essere usati per costruire circuit quantistici affidabili di dimensioni arbitrarie.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che se il teorema non fosse vero, è difficile immaginare che il Quantum Computing su larga scala
diventasse mai realtà. Ci sono molti dettagli tecnici coinvolti nelle dimostrazioni formali di questo teorema, che non cercherò di
comunicare. Ma cercherò di spiegare l'idea di base ad alto livello. E cercherò anche di collegare liberamente l'idea di base
a ciò che potremmo aspettarci che accada nella pratica. Quindi supponiamo che questo sia il nostro circuit. È lo stesso circuit di cui
abbiamo parlato per tutta la lezione. Ma di nuovo, possiamo immaginare che il nostro circuit sia significativamente più grande e complicato di questo. Vorremmo
implementare questo circuit, ma tutti i nostri componenti sono rumorosi. E assumendo che stiamo usando il modello di rumore stocastico indipendente
solo per semplicità, c'è una certa probabilità P con cui gli errori si verificano indipendentemente in ogni posizione possibile.
Se il circuit fosse significativamente più grande del reciproco di questa probabilità P, allora potremmo essere abbastanza sicuri che una
implementazione diretta di esso non funzionerebbe correttamente. Quindi passiamo attraverso tutto il lavoro di implementare il circuit
in modo tollerante ai guasti come ho discusso fino a questo punto della lezione e ci facciamo la domanda che ho sollevato prima ovvero stiamo migliorando le cose
o le stiamo peggiorando? Beh se la probabilità P che rappresenta la probabilità di errore per ciascuno dei nostri componenti è troppo grande allora
questo non ci aiuterà proprio come il codice Shore a 9 qubit non aiuta se la probabilità di errore è superiore al 3 e 3/4% circa.
In particolare, abbiamo ora reso il circuit più grande. Quindi ci sono molte più posizioni dove gli errori potrebbero colpire.
Tuttavia, se P è sufficientemente piccolo, questo ci aiuterà. E quello che faremo effettivamente è ridurre il tasso di errore
per il calcolo logico che stiamo eseguendo. Quindi pensiamo a questo in
un po' più di dettaglio. E per vedere le idee principali nel contesto più semplice possibile, supponiamo che usiamo il codice Steane a 7 qubit per la
correzione degli errori, che consente la correzione di fino a un errore per blocco di codice. Quindi affinché si verifichi un errore logico
nel circuit originale, dovranno verificarsi almeno due errori che ricadono nello stesso blocco di codice per la nostra implementazione
tollerante ai guasti.
Tenendo presente che ci sono molti modi diversi di avere due o più errori nello stesso blocco di codice, si può argomentare che la probabilità di un
errore logico in ogni posizione nel circuit originale è al massimo C * P^2 dove C è un numero che dipende dal codice e dai
gadget che usiamo. Ma in modo fondamentale, non dipende dalla dimensione del circuit originale.
Quindi se P è più piccolo del reciproco di C che è il numero che possiamo prendere come nostro valore soglia allora questo
si traduce in una riduzione dell'errore. Quindi il nostro duro lavoro nell'implementare il circuit in modo tollerante ai guasti sta dando
i suoi frutti. Tuttavia questo nuovo tasso di errore potrebbe ancora essere troppo alto perché l'intero circuit funzioni correttamente. Quindi dobbiamo fare di
più. Nella pratica una cosa naturale da fare a questo punto è scegliere un codice migliore e gadget migliori per ridurre il tasso di errore
al punto in cui l'implementazione è probabile che funzioni.
In teoria, un modo semplice per argomentare che ciò è possibile è concatenare. In altre parole, pensiamo
all'implementazione tollerante ai guasti del circuit originale come a un nuovo circuit logico. E poi lo implementiamo in modo tollerante ai
guasti. E poi lo facciamo di nuovo e ancora tante volte quante ne abbiamo bisogno. E si scopre che questo riduce l'errore
molto rapidamente. Ed è così che il teorema della soglia viene tipicamente dimostrato su carta.
Ti darò solo un'idea molto approssimativa di come diminuisce il tasso di errore tralasciando i molti dettagli tecnici necessari per
dimostrarlo formalmente. Iniziamo con la probabilità di errore P per i nostri componenti originali. E se implementiamo il
circuit in modo tollerante ai guasti, l'errore diminuisce di un fattore C * P. Se poi trattiamo la nostra implementazione tollerante ai guasti
come un circuit logico e la implementiamo in modo tollerante ai guasti, otteniamo una simile diminuzione del tasso di errore. Ma
se pensiamo al tasso di errore effettivo per il circuit originale, troviamo che scende ancora di più perché ora
stiamo sostituendo il tasso di errore P con C * P^2 perché questo è il tasso di errore effettivo dopo la prima implementazione tollerante ai guasti di primo livello.
In particolare, dopo un po' di algebra, troviamo che l'errore scende a CP^3 * P. E se
lo facciamo di nuovo, abbiamo ora un tasso di errore di CP^7 * P. E se
continuiamo a farlo per un totale di K livelli, ciò che troviamo è che l'errore si riduce in modo doppiamente esponenziale in K. Quindi
non è necessario farlo molte volte per rendere il tasso di errore estremamente piccolo.
Nel frattempo, i circuit stanno crescendo di dimensioni, ma la dimensione aumenta solo in modo semplicemente esponenziale in K perché con ogni
livello di tolleranza ai guasti, la dimensione del nostro circuit cresce al massimo di un fattore determinato dalla dimensione massima dei
nostri gadget. E quando tutto è messo insieme e viene fatta una scelta appropriata per il numero
di livelli di concatenazione, otteniamo il teorema della soglia. Ma come ho già suggerito, ci sono molti dettagli necessari per rendere questo formale. Quindi
qual è questo valore soglia nella realtà? Beh, dipende dal codice e dai gadget che
usiamo per il codice Steane insieme alla magic state distillation. È minuscolo e probabilmente difficilmente raggiungibile nella
pratica. Ma usando i surface code e gadget all'avanguardia, è stato stimato essere intorno all'1%. Il che non è
male. E man mano che vengono scoperti nuovi codici e metodi, possiamo ragionevolmente aspettarci che aumenti mentre simultaneamente il
livello di rumore nei componenti che costruiamo diminuirà. Raggiungere il punto in cui
i calcoli quantistici su larga scala possono essere implementati in modo tollerante ai guasti non sarà facile e non avverrà dall'oggi al domani.
Ma questo teorema insieme ai progressi nei codici quantistici e nell'hardware quantistico che abbiamo visto fino ad oggi
ci fornisce l'ottimismo di cui abbiamo bisogno per continuare ad andare avanti verso questo obiettivo finale di costruire un
computer quantistico tollerante ai guasti su larga scala. E questa è la fine della lezione e la fine della serie.
Spero sinceramente che tu abbia trovato valore nella serie e se è così, ti prego di considerare di consigliarla a un collega o amico.
Assicurati anche di consultare IBM Quantum Learning per corsi e tutorial aggiuntivi, e iscriviti al canale YouTube di Qiskit
se non lo hai ancora fatto, per rimanere aggiornato sulle nostre future pubblicazioni di contenuti. Grazie per
aver guardato.